What's up, gigachads, and welcome back
to the channel. Um, sorry I haven't
posted in a while for a couple of
reasons. For starters, uh, as you know,
uh, I was in Amsterdam, and I had a
roommate during that, and frankly, I'd
rather be caught than caught with a
YouTube channel. So, uh, again, [snorts]
uh, kind of was taking my time with
filming there. Uh, but now I am actually
alone in a room in Sydney, Australia.
For those of you who are Australian
watching this channel, what the hell are
you doing down here? It literally takes
a full day to get down here. I don't
understand why you're doing it. Get out
of here. It's It's too far away. You're
on the other end of the world. Okay, so
anyways, you know, with that rant about
Australia done, as nice as the weather
is, let's start making some videos
because I am a little bit behind and I
owe you guys a couple. So, today we're
going to be talking about column
oriented storage. Might as well get into
it. All right, everybody. This one's
going to be on the longer side, so bear
with me here, but we're going to go
through these things and uh hopefully it
comes out to be an interesting video. So
today basically what we're going to do
is go ahead and talk about column
oriented storage. So before we can even
talk about column oriented storage I
should probably preface the video by
talking about what row oriented storage
is. So row oriented storage is pretty
obvious. It's how you would think a
database would store its data and this
is in fact how it's typically done. So
let's imagine we have five rows in a
database. What row oriented storage will
typically do is divide those rows up
into a bunch of different chunks. And
those chunks will basically be stored
into files. So you see we've got one txt
file, another txt file. They wouldn't
really be txt files in real life, but
whatever. I just put that there as a
random suffix. And then if we're zooming
in on one row, we'll see that every
single entry of each row is adjacent to
each other on disk. Imagine this as one
big array on disk. That's how this is
going to work. So that's row oriented
storage. But let's now go ahead and talk
about column oriented storage. So
imagine we have a table with the three
fields name, email, and company.
Basically what we would do is we would
take every single value from the names
column in order and place them into one
names.txt file. Similarly, we would do
the same exact thing with email. And
then finally, we would do the same exact
thing with company. So zooming in on
company for example, adjacent to each
other on disk, we would have everyone's
company. So obviously in increasing
order of prestige, we've got Google at
the lowest, then Amazon, then Jane
Street, and then finally Albertson's the
top company. So hopefully that makes
sense. Basically the gist of it is in
row oriented storage you store the data
from one row together on disk and in
column oriented storage you store the
data from one column together on disk.
So why would we ever actually want to do
this? Well let's go ahead and talk about
it. So row oriented storage is good for
things like a web app. Imagine that
you're Facebook and typically a common
usage pattern of the data is I want to
load my entire profile. Now my entire
profile is probably or at least the
metadata of it is going to be stored in
one row of a database. And so typically
it would be really useful if we have all
of those rows stored continuously to one
another on disk. On the other hand,
let's say I'm a data science person at
Facebook and it would be really useful
to me to be able to basically perform
some analytics on some of our data. So
in in that [clears throat] basically in
that scenario, it's really really useful
to be able to basically grab all of the
values of one single column so that we
can perform some math on them. Maybe get
something like the minimum, the maximum,
the average, the sum, anything along
those lines. And so the reason again
that this is all useful all comes down
to this right here, the hard drive. The
closer that the data is together on a
hard drive, the less that arm has to
move around and the faster these
operations become. But wait, there's
more. Column oriented storage isn't just
useful because data is closer together
on disk. It's also useful because we can
perform something known as column
compression. So let's take a look at how
we might do column compression and then
I'll explain some of the advantages of
it. So, let's imagine that we have a
table as follows on the left here. And
so, this is very, you know, I'd say this
is a realistic depiction of how my time
goes whenever I go out to clubs, but
I've got seven days of me going to a
club, the club name, and then also the
number of times I get rejected by a
girl. As you can see, these are
typically spanning anywhere from 1 to
five times. So, on day 1, 2, and three,
I start off with three rejections. On
four, and five, I lose my confidence and
only get rejected once cuz I'm not even
willing to go for anything. Day six, I
say, "Screw it. Get rejected five
times." In day seven, we're back to a
happy medium of two. [snorts] So, as you
can see in the num rejections column,
which I want to do some analytics on,
there are only going to be values from 1
to 5. Now, of course, you know, if the
values can be literally anything and
there's no pattern to them, that is a
different story and it's harder to
perform column compression. Column
compression is easiest to perform when
the data within the column is very
similar to one another. So, let's do an
example of column compression. So, we
can do two things. First, we would
perform a bit map encoding and then we
could perform a run length encoding. So
if you go over here and look at what we
have on the right, for example, for the
number one aka times where I get
rejected once per night, you can see
that the first three lines here, here,
and here are uh not ones. So I would put
three zeros representing those in the
bit map encoding. The next two lines are
ones. So that's why we have 1 one. And
then finally, we can end that with 0 0
because five and two are not equal to
one. Okay, so [snorts] we have our bit
map encoding. And then now we can
actually go ahead and convert that even
further into a run length encoding. So a
run length encoding is basically taking
the number of zeros and putting a number
for it. Then the number of ones and then
the number of zeros again in your bitmap
encoding. So as you can see it starts
out with three zeros. Then we have two
ones and then again two zeros. Hence the
number 322. So as you can see I've
basically encoded everything in terms of
its bit map and its run length encoding.
And I've left the number five to do for
ourselves. So let's go ahead and do
that. So basically the first three
things are going to be threes. So that's
0 0 0. The next two are ones. So that's
0 0. The next one is a five. So that's
our one. And then finally the last one
is a two. So that's going to be a zero
again. And so looking at this that means
our run length encoding starts with five
zeros then has a single one and then
goes back to another zero. So 5 1. So,
as you can see, this has allowed us to
seriously compress down our data in a
column where many of the metrics in
there are actually going to be very
similar. If there's a lot of repeat
values if the values next to each other
are similar, that is really, really
useful in terms of reducing the size.
So, what are the benefits of column
compression? [snorts] Well, for
starters, uh there's a lot less data
that actually has to be sent over the
network. If I am say trying to do some
analytics on a column and I want to load
all of those values onto my personal
computer, it means that that query is
going to run a lot faster, which is
super useful if you're a data scientist
and you want to speed up your workflows.
Secondly, and even more importantly, now
we can actually keep more of that data
stored in memory or in our CPU cache,
which allows us to perform faster
queries. Obviously, disk is going to be
quite a bit slower than these other
forms of data storage. And so, as a
result, the more that we can fit in
there, the better. That's what she said.
Anyways, um moving onwards, we can
actually do some more compression on
this data. So, let's go back to my
previous example, uh in which um I was
talking about basically all the clubs
that I go to. And so, what we're going
to perform on these is called dictionary
compression where we take arbitrary
strings of basically a finite set and
we're able to compress them to only a
few bits. So in this case, dictionary
compression works because I've only got
uh five different clubs here. And so as
you can see, I've got five distinct
clubs in this list. So let me go ahead
and write that five distinct. And when
you have five distinct clubs, that means
you can represent those with just three
bits. Why three bits? Because 2 to the^
of 3 is 8, which means you can represent
up to eight things with three bits. If I
had only four distinct clubs, I could
use two bits. Hopefully that makes
sense. So I create this dictionary right
here where I take all of these bit
values and map them to a club. So go
ahead and look over here on our right. I
say that the club 000 is live, 001 is
marquee, 010 is leane, uh 011 is 11, and
then 10 is the DL. [snorts] So now I can
actually take this column that was
previously taking up quite a bit more
space because every single character is
two bytes and actually go ahead and
convert those to just a few different
values of three bits. If you think about
that, that is saving us a ton of
storage. And again, the more storage
that we save, the less data there is to
send over the network, the more data
that we can fit in our caches.
So that's obviously going to be a really
big deal. And then finally, the last
thing that I kind of want to talk about
in terms of a feature of column oriented
storage is known as predicate pushdown.
So basically, predicate pushdown is a
feature of something called parket or
maybe it's not specifically a feature of
parket, but that's how I've heard of it.
So, Parket is effectively an open-
source Apache file format that allows
you to perform column oriented storage.
And so, it makes things easy for you.
And the really nice thing about this is
that what it actually do is it'll take a
column like so. As you can see, we've
got column one right here. And it'll
divide the values into a bunch of
different chunks. And so, as you can
see, you know, the first few values of
the column go into file 1.txt. The next
few go into file 2.txt. And then so on,
basically until you reach the end of
those values. And within these files, we
actually store some metadata about the
data points in them. So, for example, if
they're numeric, we might have the
minimum value, say 60, the maximum value
is 80, the sum of the values 10,000, and
the average is 70. And so, we have these
useful little pieces of metadata. The
reason being that uh they can actually
speed up our queries if used properly.
So, let's say I wanted to run a SQL
query where I want to find all the rows
where the value stored in column 1 is
greater than 60. Well, if you look at
file 2.txt and the metadata surrounding
it, you can see that the max value
within that column chunk is actually
going to be 55. So, what we can do here
is perform something known as a
predicate push down where we basically
just go ahead and skip querying this
part of the data. This is going to speed
up our query considerably because this
metadata basically gives us hints about
where we actually have to look in the
data for the results that we want. Okay,
so I hope that makes sense. Those are
three pretty interesting things that you
can do with column oriented storage to
save both time and space with your data.
But are there any downsides of column
oriented storage? Well, yeah, I would
say so. For starters, every single
column has to have the same sort order.
So, that's annoying, but it's just the
only thing that makes sense. Otherwise,
your data would not be sensical, right?
If I had different sort orders within
all of the files that store my columns,
well, how would I be able to tell, you
know, which piece of data corresponded
to which? I wouldn't. So they have to be
sorted in the same way. It is possible
that you could basically duplicate all
of your files and have a separate copy
of the data with a different sort order.
That's feasible. And you know that's
kind of something you would have to
weigh the trade-offs. Is it worth it for
me to store all of this extra data? Does
it speed up my queries enough to justify
that? But again, that's specific to your
application. Additionally, uh we have
another question of basically each write
needs to go to many different places.
Why is that? Well, because we're writing
one row at a time, but every single
element from the row needs to go to a
different file. Or does it? Well,
actually, we've discussed kind of a data
indexing structure that allows us to get
around this and make things a lot
easier. So, what we can actually do, if
we all recall our LSM tree and SS table
based index, which I hope you do, I
recommend watching that video if you
haven't yet, is we can basically write
our rows to an LSM tree. So an LSM tree
to just give a quick refresher is an
in-memory balanced binary search tree.
And basically all we can do is go ahead
and write our entire row to that. So
again it is column oriented storage but
for now we're just going to write the
entire row to our LSM tree. Why? Because
when this thing gets too big
we can go ahead and flush it all to disk
and do bulk writes of all of these
basically column oriented files. And of
course, you know, if down the line we
want to rearrange the sort order of
these files, we know that uh basically
there's going to be SS table compression
down the line and those can get merged
in in all the same ways, thus preserving
the sort order. So yeah, uh hopefully
this was clear. Basically the gist of it
is you write your row data to the LSM
tree and then uh this way we can just
write our column oriented files in bulk
as opposed to you know having to
basically write to a bunch of different
places at once and especially having to
write into the middle of a sorted list
which takes forever because then you
have to move all the other uh indexes
out of the way. So again the LSM tree is
definitely the way to go here. All right
guys, well I hope this video helped. Um
going to try and get one more out. uh
hopefully this weekend and that is going
to be about you know serialization
frameworks. I think that that should be
the last video that I need to cover
where it's like what's going on in a
single database node and then after that
we can start talking about replication,
partitioning, SQL, NoSQL, all that good
stuff and uh really get into distributed
systems. So have a great day and I will
see you in the next one.